senators get one last chance to question
supreme court nominee amy coney barrett
in a marathon confirmation hearing
yesterday senate judiciary committee
members
grilled the appeals court judge for
nearly 12
hours like other recent nominees barrett
did not discuss how she would decide
cases
on the high court she repeatedly made
the point that she has
no policy agenda and did not want to be
used as
a quote pawn nancy cordes is covering
the barrett hearings nancy what can we
expect today
well anthony today senators on the
committee will get 20 minutes
each to follow up on questions that they
feel were not answered yesterday which
as far as democrats are concerned covers
a lot of territory
but republicans like the fact that
barrett is being cautious
they think that barring some major
stumble today
victory is in sight i have made no
precommitments to anyone about how i
would decide a case
barrett insisted tuesday she does not
have it out for obamacare i'm
not here on a mission to destroy the
affordable care act
but democratic vp nominee kamala harris
argued barrett's past criticisms
including a 2017 article suggests
otherwise
how many months after you published that
article
did president trump nominate you to be a
judge on the court of appeals
i believe my nomination to the court of
appeals was announced
in may of 2017.
that's correct but i don't remember when
the article came out
the article was published in january of
2017 so that would have been five months
later
a hearing for a supreme court justice
has never been held
this close to a presidential election
will you commit to recusing yourself
from any case arising from a dispute in
the presidential election
results three weeks from now i certainly
hope that all members of the committee
have more confidence in my integrity
than to think that i would allow myself
to be used as a pawn to decide this
election
democrats tried unsuccessfully tuesday
to pin barrett down
on issues like abortion are you willing
to say that roe was correctly decided
it's inconsistent with the duties of a
sitting judge
to take positions on cases that the
court has decided in the past
louisiana republican john kennedy argued
that judges personal views are
irrelevant
because they take an oath of
impartiality anyway
are you going to take that oath and
affirm it
if you're confirmed yes
you're not lying i'm not lying i took
that oath before
i began as a judge on the seventh
circuit and i have not violated that
oath and i would
take it again and oaths are serious
to me there were some tense moments
tuesday after
barrett declined to say whether she
agreed with the court's decision
legalizing same-sex marriage i do want
to be clear
that i have never discriminated on the
basis of sexual preference
hawaii senator maisie hirono sexual
preference is an offensive and outdated
term
it is used by anti-lgbtq activists
to suggest that sexual orientation is a
choice
i certainly didn't mean and you know
would never mean
to use a term that would cause any
offense in the lgbtq community
so if i did i greatly apologize for that
at one point during the hearing judge
barrett was asked to hold up the notes
that she had in front of her and
you can see she held up a blank page
which was meant to highlight the fact
that she was answering
hours and hours of questions about
detailed legal arguments
without any doubts at all tony blank
page but not a blank mind nancy thank
you very much